the movie starts at the annual united
nations global warming conference in new
delhi where paleoclimatologist jack hall
is giving a speech he warns the
delegates that the earth is soon going
to face a polar catastrophe which will
turn everything into ice when some of
the delegates inquire about the time
left jack mentions that it may take some
centuries but if the usage of fossil
fuel isn't lessened their own
grandchildren will face the consequences
after the conference jack meets a
representative from the national oceanic
and atmospheric administration terry
rapson and the duo begin chatting about
their respective findings as they
discuss it snows heavily implying that
climate change has already begun or
maybe it's just winter over the course
of the next few weeks strange weather
conditions strike different parts of the
world in japan monstrous blocks of
hailstones start falling from the sky
leaving several people dead such
hailstones are the largest that have
ever been recorded in history meanwhile
at terry rapson's monitoring station in
scotland the computers reveal that parts
of the ocean are suffering massive drops
in temperature the drops are so sudden
and mysterious that the communication
signals placed there have frozen
instantly elsewhere at the international
space station astronauts notice gigantic
storms brewing up in the earth's
troposphere in the next scene we are
taken to washington dc where jack is
dropping his son sam at the airport sam
is a genius student who has been invited
to participate in a decathlon in new
york though his father is a well-known
man sam appears to be angry with him as
jack has always been absent from his
life due to his busy work schedule
nonetheless he assures sam that once he
retires he will have all the time in the
world for his family unless they're all
dead later when sam along with his best
friends laura and brian arrive at new
york they notice a large flock of birds
flying towards the west as if they are
trying to escape something in the
meantime terry calls jack from his
monitoring station and informs him about
his findings he says that the polar
catastrophe is approaching them rapidly
and that they have no time to escape it
when jack inquires if it is bad terry
replies that something like this hasn't
happened in the last 10 000 years
following this we are taken to a weather
monitoring center in california where a
technician is enjoying his time with his
girlfriend just then he receives a
distress call from a man who reveals
that it is raining hailstones in la
hearing this the technician turns on the
television and is taken aback to see
that hailstones the size of golf balls
have ravaged parts of the city he
immediately calls his boss and tells him
to issue a tornado warning in the state
of california however it's too late in
no time several gigantic tornadoes
circle the city and destroy everything
in sight must have been one hell of a
gender reveal party because of this an
emergency meeting is conducted at the
office of global change in washington dc
one of the attendees mentions the other
destructive weather occurrences in
different parts of the world and asserts
that something has gone wrong just then
jack who is also among the attendees
reveals to the crowd that everything is
happening due to the north atlantic
currents the currents are brought upon
by the rapidly melting polar ice which
in turn is caused by global warming he
also mentions that it is just the
beginning and in a few days the weather
will become worse in the next scene jack
meets with the vice president and tries
to make him understand that the
situation is very critical he mentions
that the polar blast could hit any time
so mass evacuations in the northern
states are necessary however the vp is
an idiot doesn't take him seriously and
walks away elsewhere in the uk it has
started snowing at a rapid rate so three
helicopters are sent to the royal palace
to retrieve the queen however on their
way they pass through the eye of the
storm which causes their instruments to
freeze instantly in no time the chopper
blades also stop working and all the
three helicopters crash to the ground
one pilot manages to survive the crash
but as soon as he opens the door he is
frozen to death back to manhattan sam
and his friends try to get back to dc
but all the transport services have been
derailed by the heavy downpour desperate
to get out of the city the trio walked
to the streets only to find the city in
utter chaos just then a massive tsunami
appears out of nowhere and begins
sweeping the place the skyscrapers and
even the statue of liberty is engulfed
as if they are nothing sam and his group
see the impending danger and rush to the
national library hall for safety sadly
thousands of not-so-lucky people are
washed away and killed later terry calls
jack and informs him about the freezing
air over europe which brought down the
helicopters this alarms jack and after a
bit of research he finds out that the
storm is approaching the u.s sooner than
expected in fact they only have 48 hours
before everything freezes over following
this he opens the weather prediction
which shows that three colossal weather
systems are forming in different parts
of the world they are getting larger by
the day and in europe the polar state
has already begun meanwhile sam
desperately searches for a telephone in
the library as the place does not have
any mobile phone reception after a while
he descends to another floor and finds a
telephone which is almost submerged in
the water desperate to call his parents
he swims to the place and finally makes
a call jack is delighted to find that
his son is alive and starts giving him
instructions put on some water wingies
and don't die son he tells sam that he
must stay indoors and wait for the storm
to pass if he ventures outside he is
going to freeze to death instantly
hearing this sam becomes worried but
jack consoles him by saying that he will
come to rescue him soon the next day as
everyone in the library is gathering
clothes and rations they hear a strange
noise from outside when they peek
through the window they are shocked to
see a cargo ship sailing through the
place elsewhere in dc the head of the
state is having a meeting and jack is
tasked with briefing the state of the
situation before even beginning he
instills fear in everyone by mentioning
that the worst is yet to come he then
suggests that the residents of the
southern states must be evacuated
immediately and moved to mexico once
again the vice president disapproves of
the idea as he claims that an evacuation
of such magnitude is not possible at
least he didn't build a stupid-ass wall
he also asks what will happen to the
residents of the north to which jack
replies that it's too late for them if
they step out of their homes they will
immediately freeze to death the best
they can do is stay inside their houses
and wait for the storm to subside
surprisingly the president takes jack's
advice and orders the national guard to
evacuate the remaining population to the
south in new york the people inside the
library see a group of people walking on
the frozen land and to deduce that
they're heading to the warmer states as
a result they also decide to venture
outside before the snow gets any deeper
sam knowing about the impending danger
tries to warn everyone that it's a death
mission but he is completely ignored
soon everyone leaves the library with
the exception of sam's group and a few
other people meanwhile jack starts his
trip to new york along with his
colleagues and best buddies frank and
jason since the three have visited the
arctic several times for research
purposes they are accustomed to the
weather back at the library sam and his
group scan through the whole building
for food and to discover some vending
machines they also gather some books for
burning in the fireplace elsewhere as
jack and his crew are traveling through
the thick snow they suddenly hit a
roadblock and are forced to continue
their journey on foot they walk for a
few hours with utmost dedication but
unfortunately when they reach the top of
a fragile building frank breaks the
glass and falls in he is caught by the
lifeline and the two friends are holding
him up but just then the glass starts to
crack hence left with no choice he cuts
his lifeline and sacrifices himself so
that his friends can continue their
mission at the library laura suddenly
gets a fever and falls unconscious
worried the group starts searching for
the cause and discovers that she has a
wound in her leg which might have caused
her blood poisoning one of the ladies in
the group who happens to be a medic
mentions that laura needs an urgent
injection of penicillin or else she will
have to be amputated desperate to save
his friend because those legs go for
days sam decides to venture into a
nearby cargo ship hoping that it
contains some medicine as he is about to
leave brian and another guy jd also
decide to accompany him in the next
scene the vp who is now stationed in a
military base finds out that the
president met with an accident and died
while being evacuated to make matters
worse the researchers also find out that
the eye of the storm has shifted its
course to new york city elsewhere jack
and jason are slowly moving towards
their destination but sadly jason
collapses due to exhaustion as a result
jack is forced to carry his friend at
the library the trio finally heads out
and makes their way to the cargo ship
however along the way their scent is
caught by a pack of hungry wolves who
have broken out from the nearby zoo we
just met jd so he's dead for sure sam
brian and jd enter the cargo ship's
kitchen and find some penicillin they
then look around the place for more
supplies but suddenly they're attacked
by the pack of wolves sam and brian
managed to escape to another room but jd
is severely bitten i knew it still they
managed to save him from the hungry
beasts as the three brainstorm different
ideas to escape the situation sam looks
outside and sees the skies clearing he
then realizes that the eye of the storm
is nearing them and that they don't have
enough time left hence he puts himself
in harm's way and makes his way outside
to lure the wolves away from the kitchen
he then runs through the abandoned ship
narrowly escaping the wolves after a
while he catches up with his friends but
by this time jd is unable to stand hence
sam and brian bring a sledge and drag
their friend to the library on the other
hand as jack is dragging jason through
the thick snow he also notices the eye
approaching at a rapid speed wasting no
time he starts rummaging through the
snow for any houses fortunately he finds
an open vent and throws jason inside
before getting in himself as soon as he
closes the door the frost attacks the
place and freezes everything that it
touches the boys also reach the library
just in time and narrowly avoid death
they then scramble to keep the fire
running as it is the only thing that can
save them from the brutal cold jack also
desperately tries to light a fire and
manages to do so with an open stove
after a while jason wakes up and notices
that the entire place has been covered
with ice now with the eye of the storm
already gone jack plans to resume his
mission jason tries to make him
understand that it's still dangerous
outside but jack asserts that he doesn't
have any time left that night the two
sleep in a tent and contemplate the
future of humanity jack mentions that
humans have survived ice ages many times
but if they are not careful enough they
might go extinct in this one finally
after weeks of disastrous weather
conditions the international space
station spots some good signs they
notice that the storm is dissipating in
europe as they see land mass for the
first time in several weeks at the same
time jack also gets out of the tent and
sees that the skies have cleared the sun
has also come out after walking for a
while the two come across the frozen
statue of liberty and several ships
which have sunk into the ice they have
finally reached manhattan after enduring
days of excruciating pain and suffering
however when they reach the exact
location of the library with the help of
a gps they are devastated to learn that
it has been completely swallowed by ice
with all hope now gone the two prepare
to leave but just then they notice a
small opening in the snow wasting no
time jack enters the library through the
opening and jason follows him closely
the two then begin looking for sam and
fortunately after a bit of looking
around find him it turns out that sam
and his group are still alive because of
the fire with this the father-son duo
finally meet after weeks of separation
amidst the terrifying weather conditions
following this the scene cuts to mexico
where the new president is informed that
there are survivors in new york the news
excites him and he announces live on
television that he will be initiating a
major rescue operation to retrieve
anyone who is stranded in the northern
states in the final scene of the movie
the choppers reach manhattan where
several people are found to be alive
they have gathered on the rooftops
waiting to be rescued the helicopters
also reached jack and his group who are
finally taken to the south the movie
ends as an astronaut from the
international space station gazes at the
earth and remarks that it is the
clearest sky that he has ever seen he
also says i can see bezos's rocket from
here subscribe for more videos like this
turn on notifications and leave a like
to help the channel out thank you for
watching